evening members um
count members and officers and members
of the public
welcome to the cabinet meeting on the
28th of april
um just some housekeeping
if the fire alarm
is activated vacate the offices via the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assembling hawley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off
or turn to silent your mobile phones and
do not make or receive calls whilst the
meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
stream for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
that's a no i believe
the following members have asked to
speak under council rule
council procedure rule 20.1 item 4
councillors keane yates and whitehead
item five councillors austin wing
christensen and whitehead item six
councillor yates item seven councillor
eight yates does anyone
no one wants to speak on item eight ah
item five's very popular um
councillor duckworth
okay we have a note of those
just remind me if i overlook you when we
get there
there are no apologies for absence this
evening
does anyone have any interest to declare
any items of business on the agenda this
evening minutes of the previous meeting
to approve the summary of
recommendations and the decision of the
cabinet held on the 17th of march 2022
i propose we move the minutes
do i have a second councillor bob
bayford
do members agree
item 4
asset management old town hall to
introduce councillor reese pugh
thank you chair uh members will see in
the uh in the agenda um the council
council wishes to seek a tenant for the
old town hall in margay under a new
lease agreement
um a letting would provide an ongoing
revenue stream for us and help mitigate
against its empty property costs
which currently stand at circa thirteen
and a half thousand pounds per year as a
cost to the council for ongoing
maintenance insurance utilities and
rates and stuff like that
a significant amount of renovation work
is required to bring the old town hall
up to standard and this will be
reflected in a new any new lease deal
um
either by reflecting this in the initial
lease price asked or buy a friend a
rent-free period in the first year
um or reduce rent over say to one or two
years if required and subject
to negotiation
uh therefore i would like to put to
my fellow cabinet members that we decide
on approving the following
recommendations first to let the
property via a commercial lease
second to give delegated authority to
the director of property in consultation
with the principal surveyor to market
the premises and negotiate heads of
terms for a lease
and number three give delegated
authority to the director of law and
democracy to sign all documents
necessary to give effect to the disposal
thank you
thank you councillor pugh
to speak under 20.1
councillor king
thank you leader um the future of the
old town hall is an important decision
for margate the building is an integral
part of the town's history and i'm
pleased that action is being considered
to address the deterioration of this
heritage building it was previously
considered by the council in 2018 but no
action followed and the deterioration
has continued
it is a shame that no proposals from the
community are considered to have met the
required standards for the building to
continue as a community asset but i'm
pleased that the plan is for thanet
council to retain ownership and to the
building to be leased out to include
repairing the property
however this is a grade two listed
building and i'm concerned a commercial
development would need to substantially
alter the interior to make it suitable
for their purposes this would clearly
involve planning consent which i hope
will be sensitive to retaining the
character of the interior
the building also houses the vault and
adjoins the margate museum and provides
a fire exit
although it was the previous home of the
charter trustees there has been no
communication with the charter trustees
and i believe margate museum an issue
that should be addressed immediately
finally we learnt from the experience
with dreamland that a long lease can in
effect mean that the asset is as good as
sold i hope this will be given full
consideration when the terms of the
lease are drawn up
thank you
council appeal would you like to respond
thank you councillor keane uh all of
that certainly will be taken into
consideration i think it's important to
note as well as you said um that the
council explored the option for you know
trying to do something with the old town
hall in in 2018 um it's important that
we move on this rather than have
buildings such as this continue to
deteriorate and then not be used
so that's of course our priority i think
uh particularly the old town hall this
is a as i said an opportunity for us to
create a significant revenue stream for
the council while still retaining
ownership of the building um
there may be a significant renovation
cost as i think i already stated um but
of course we can at least try and see
what uh
ambition there is uh particularly for a
commercial lease and if there isn't then
we'll go back to the drawing board but
you know let's let's see what what will
what will come in
thank you councillor pugh um
speak under 20.1 councillor yates
thank you um
so this question's about
cultural and heritage well it's about
the old town hall of course but it's
about the leveling up fund round two um
i have heard that it is it's not
possible that the leveling up from round
two can be used but i would just like to
question that because that this fund is
there for specifically for uh cultural
and heritage assets and on part of the
website it does say mps can provide
formal priority support to one bid in
this round this means mps who can who
provided formal broad support to
unsuccessful unsuccessful bids in the
first round can provide formal priority
support in a bid to a bid in this round
so just one complete clarity yes or no
can mps
um apply uh for
doing up assets uh within that because
there's not only the old town hall
there's also winter gardens as well
which is um
prime for some government money to be
done up thank you
um
my understanding and the leveling up is
that you have one one shot at it the mps
only get one shot for their district um
which has obviously been fulfilled with
the margate digital but i would
ask uh louise askew if she could just
confirm that that is the situation
regarding the leveling up funds to
confirm that thank you
yes so
each constituent area can submit one bid
with support from the mp and we have had
both for ramsgate and margate support
from our mps for those bids which means
over the whole of the leveling up fund
program so round one and round two we've
had our allocation of bids
hopefully that
i think you'll find sir roger gail is
using his second round bidding for home
bay because that's outside of our
district but
i'm glad that he's able to use his
bidding
um allowance for another district
because that's that's good it's all
about the whole area being leveled up so
thank you for confirming that louise and
um
uh councillor pugh
yeah thank you leader thank you chad i
just wanted to say also as well that of
course um
as as louise has just just explained um
the process and the constraints that
there are let's not forget that you know
we do have margot digital um you know
and that that uh leveling up bid that we
were incredibly successful with which we
only got in just in the nick of time and
of course if more
uh support had been probably given to
that um and officers were able to uh
prepare for that we probably could have
put in
uh you know a bigger application and a
bigger ask
but unfortunately we weren't so i'm not
going to get into the security of that
and the blame game but unfortunately
that situation and that's where we are
okay um next to speak under 20.1
councillor whitehead
thank you very much leader
as historically we've previously had
struggles with the enforcement of full
repairing leases on our buildings
and considering the listed nature and
historical significance of the old town
hall
will council be given not only
information on the estimated costs of
full repairs but also proposed
enforcement procedures for the full
repairing lease and the time scale for
major repairs within the arranged lease
to ensure overview of the upkeep of this
important building
thank you
thank you you'd like to respond
counselor
thank you thank you chair um thank you
council whitehead um
i'm sure that's something that we could
look into and we can explore uh with the
property team um of course we want to
make sure that you know if we do sign
over a commercial lease that you know
the works are then commenced and that it
is properly used um
i can't give more of a
confirmation of that than i can but of
course i'll check back with the officers
and i'll get back to you on that because
i'm sure if any information that we can
share i'd be happy for all members to
to see it
thank you catsupee
uh chief executive you'd like to just
come in as well
yes really just to uh you know confirm
really a councillor pew's commentary
there i mean in effect what you're
talking about is the lease itself and
i'm sure you know within reason beyond
any commercial sensitivity issues we can
share the content of the lease which
will contain all of the elements that
you're talking about
thank you
and finally to speak under 20.1 on this
item uh counselor dot
yeah i just wanted to ask um
there's going to be a saving of thirteen
thousand five hundred a year it says in
the report um just
um on
[Music]
the costs that you're paying at the
moment so it's just uh wonder wondering
what you're going to do with that you
know it doesn't seem like a lot but
maybe some um
maintenance of some of the parks that
missed out some of the children's play
areas and things like that missed out on
the recent funding round
um
councillor pugh i'm not sure if you have
the answer to that or if there's an
officer you can
look to say thank you chair uh council
of cups just indicated he's happy if the
money goes to open spaces and parks and
players um i haven't decided what i'll
be spending the money on um it doesn't
particularly go into my current account
um but um but you're right councillor
duckworth you know if we if we can um
secure a commercial lease and that
creates a saving uh for the council and
of course then there's the revenue on
top of what we'll then get for it as
well so i'm sure that we can
explore ways that we can we can we can
spend that
sorry i'm sure i'm sure matt can has
already spent it but um perhaps he'd
like to tell us where
it's not that we've spent it is that
effectively there'd be no assumption
about a saving it would just be
redistributed to repairs elsewhere
within the organization so it's
effectively ring fence for the repair
spot where we under provide anyway so
yes um a very good financial answer
there um but i would like to reiterate
the fact that it's not so much about the
saving of that is the fact that it's six
the the ambition is for 65 000 to go
into
into our revenue um which is what really
we need to be about looking you know
that's what we need to be looking at
obviously
you know community
asset transfers and bids etc
need to be brought into the mix but
there are some times when it is makes
commercial sense for the council to
actually go seeking for for sizable
rents and it is a magnificent building
and we we want it to be restored back to
its magnificent uh self um but we also
need to earn some revenue at it and it's
just sad that it's been sat there for so
long
um decaying and uh not earning any
revenue
councils really do need to maximize
their revenue on their assets so um
i'm looking forward to
the market testing to see
who comes forward i hope it's going to
be very popular
yes
councillor pew if you would like to
reiterate the recommendations and move
the item yes thank you chair um
one recommendation to let the property
via commercial lease two to give
dedicated authority to the director of
property in consultation with the
principal surveyor to market the
premises and negotiate heads of terms
for release and three give delegated
authority to the director of law and
democracy to sign all documents
necessary to give effect to the disposal
so that has been um
moved by councillor pew do i have a
seconder councillor david saunders
do members agree
item 5
town center parking review update to
introduce councillor david saunders
thank you leader and i'm pleased to see
uh the level of interest from other
members on what is
a complex
subject and
somewhat
provocative
subject particularly
considering the level of inconsiderate
parking that we appear to
experience
during the summer months in particular
on january the 12th at the town council
meeting councillor crittenden proposed a
motion to council that the growth of
town center
residential developments throughout the
district are putting pressure on the
residential and visitor parking to the
detriment of both residents and visitors
and i think we all agree with that
whilst it is within the local plan in
accordance with the national policy and
consistent with climate change targets
that parking facilities will not be
required or expected for residential
development planning applications within
the town centers
this does not take into account the
needs of workers especially key workers
or residents with disabilities who
genuinely need access to their own
transport
few of these those most affected are
not necessarily within areas that are
covered by the residential parking
schemes or in a position to pay for the
annual season tickets for our car parks
the result has been increased pressure
on what limited parking is available in
the street surrounding our town centres
and beyond
seneca district council recognizes these
challenges and commits to undertake a
district-wide impact assessment of
increased pressures on both on and off
street parking in our town centres
arising from the expansion of town
centre residential development
taking into account relevant factors
such as access to electric vehicle
charging public transport links
cycle storage and pedestrian safety
especially can i say at night
in consultation with kcc world
councillors other stakeholders
i.e
public transport providers and the
public in general in order to develop
solutions that support the community
recognizing the need for some groups to
have access to safe personal transport
due to work conditions or disadvantage
this motion was debated at the town
council meeting on the 12th
and then forwarded to cabinet this
evening this paper discusses this and
proposes that cabinet agreed to
undertake a well evidenced strategic
review of parking access the district
within the district and then develop a
district-wide parking strategy something
i'm very very keen on therefore i
propose that we agree recommendations
3.1 in the report this evening and that
reads agree to undertake a well evident
strategic review of parking access
uh the district and then develop a
district-wide parking strategy thank you
leah
thank you councillor saunders to speak
under 20.1 first i have councillor
austin
thank you leader
i'm very keen to support this idea
obviously as council saunders has
highlighted and as council crittenden
highlighted in her motion as a council
that's declared a climate emergency we
want to reduce the
amount of use of petrol vehicles but we
see that this can't be achieved
overnight we also need to be keeping up
pressure on public transport providers
if we're ever going to make our towns
friendly to
users of public transport and
pedestrians so as part of the work that
we do on this i would urge cabinet to
be liaising strongly with public
transport providers and also to be
looking at the planning of
town centres so that they are more
pedestrian friendly and more cyclist
friendly
with regard to the sorts of things that
councillor saunders has highlighted
around inconsiderate parking which
obviously causes huge difficulties for
example for our waste collection and uh
emergency vehicles
a general strategy of reducing on-street
parking and making better use of our car
parks seems to be a sensible way to go
but in order to do that we need to give
the consultant permission to think
completely outside the box for example
in ramsgate we had a proposal from a
developer to work with us
to do some building on one of our car
parks which would actually have retained
the same number of parking spaces as we
have now or possibly increase them but
that was not something that anybody took
up successive cabinet members or senior
officers which seems a shame
any kind of partnership that might help
improve our parking facilities seems to
me to be worth consideration and i would
urge that cabinet encourage the
consultant to think as widely as
possible about this i'm also a little
concerned about the idea that a
district-wide parking strategy might
mean that we think we have to have
exactly the same type of facilities and
the same arrangements in every part of
the district which seems inappropriate
because we've got variety of different
needs across the district for example i
know council clinton suggested
previously that staffordshire street car
park which is
massively underused that part of that
could actually be fenced off for
residents parking and i believe was told
that
that if that happened in ramsgate it
would have to happen everywhere and yet
we have on-street parking arrangements
that are radically different in
different parts of the district for
example in
ramsgate we have uh traders who would be
delighted give their eye teeth to have
the 20-minute or 30-minute free on
street parking that there are in some
other areas of the district so we're
very keen to see i think uh a consistent
strategy and a strategy that covers the
whole area but we don't want to see the
consultant's hands tied by making trying
to make everything exactly the same
across the whole area thank you
council saunders if you'd like to
respond i would indeed thanks for the
comment and i absolutely agree that um
we need to move um
parking off of the street onto our own
car parks because of course that
increases our revenue
and
rather than it go
into the decrim fund and ultimately kcc
i'd much prefer it to come into our own
coffers so that we can make good use of
that to uh enforce uh the situation much
better than we do at the moment so thank
you very much for your comments so would
we all thank you councilman
yes and obviously cancer saunas will
give the consultant um who i'm sure
consultants are
they do have a tendency to be able to
think outside the box it's just
a case of um we will ensure that he has
a or she has a very wide ranging thought
process on it
next to speak under 20.1 councillor wing
thank you obviously we supported the
motion and i'm really glad that it's
that we're moving this forward because
apart from waste parking and car parking
is my second most moan that i get
i've been working with residents really
for the last 12 months
abiding by covered rules mainly meetings
outside and it started with residents
telling me they wanted residence parking
schemes
but as we as we talked over the 12-month
period other people joined us on spencer
square at two meter distance sometimes
was
quite a lot of us and sometimes not not
many of us but we we other topics became
relevant so care workers one of them
consistently being fined
because they cannot find anywhere to
park obviously the impact of uh tourism
tourist workers
and the negative impact of residents
parking which is to push everything back
so nelson crescent and uh the paragon
they're quite happy with their residence
parking but it means that everything's
pushed back and there are available
spaces during the day
residents i found have a great deal of
knowledge and information and a very
real lived experience of parking in
their communities and like trees like
council of boston said it's it has to be
put in the context of your community
they also have some very good ideas
actually and obviously some very real
concerns
will the cabinet ensure the following
happens of part of the review of
consultation which i i welcome and the
residents welcome residents are
consulted and form part of the process
and i don't just mean we hand out a
survey monkey questionnaire that we
actually do some of the type of
engagement that the residents did with
me even if it is standing in spencer
square
at two meter distance from each other
they really do have some good ideas
that there is a review of the peasant
present situation including residents
parking to identify both positives and
negatives again there are some real
positives with residents parking and
there are some huge negatives and they
they need to be looked at
three the co as as councillor austrian
said that the context of the communities
is considered so parking at palm bay is
going to be completely different to
parking in the middle of ramsgate or
broadstairs and then it will be
completely different in the wintertime
and the summer time
one size doesn't fit all
can we can we try and get some serious
joined up thinking because part of the
problem i think
with with residents parking and the
reason nobody wants to a visitor is not
going to park in residence parking is
the cost per hour and for me if we can
reduce the cost per hour
so it's less stick and more carrot then
maybe we can force some of those
builders and those visitors to actually
use our multi story in ramsgate rather
than try and find the free parking spots
behind our residence parking scheme i
don't think there's a we've done enough
about looking at if we introduce this
what's the impact on that and we
definitely need to start looking at what
we've got and try and identify i also
think signage is a big problem if you
come into ramsgate there's no signs
directing you to that multi-story car
park
so yet signage is another big thing
also we've got two electric charging
points and it's a real issue for for our
residents i know electric cars are uh
there are some you know
all sorts of opinions over electric cars
and there and their the battery
recycling but we have a lot of residents
that are moving to hybrids and electric
cars there are two available points in
ramsgate both in the car park neither of
them work and again we need we need to
be we need to be looking at and it's not
just about looking at the parking it's
about looking at our planning why why
are some of our developments not having
automatic charging points in why have we
got a residence parking scheme that
hasn't got allocated charging points
that have come out of
come out of lamp posts we can put the
parking meters there so obviously we can
access the electrics i just think we
need to
we need to have a complete review and i
i hope that this this review will work
coming from the local plan i mean it's
often said that i want people to not
have cars and i would love people to not
have cards and actually we've got one of
the the lowest car ownerships in the
country
the local plan clearly states that free
for every 116 people that are actively
working a hundred of them have to travel
out of thanet to work so the reality of
just saying
we don't need cars is not there because
the reality for our workers is they
actually need to leave thanit to get
employment we are surrounded by the sea
on three sides so i think we have to get
some reality about what we can and can't
expect our residents to do and at this
present moment in time they need to
drive cars to work
so i absolutely welcome this this review
i'm hoping that both residents and world
councillors can be an active part of it
and i really hope that we come with some
positive changes thank you
thank you councilloring councillor
saunders there's quite a lot of points
to go back on but um
i'm not going to cover all the points
but thank you councillor wing and uh
thank you for mentioning spencer square
on four occasions i haven't forgotten
spencer square
but as far as the strategy is concerned
i've got your name down as one of the
consultees
because i think you've got some good
ideas i think they're absolutely right
but i said right at the start that it
can be a provocative
subject parking
we have looked at it in the past we
looked at equalizing the parking charges
throughout the distance
district because there was a time when
i was being told that it's cheaper to
park in cliftonville than it is in broad
stairs etc etc so we tried to harmonize
the parking um but yeah once we get into
it i'll ensure um because i do get a lot
of contact and i know penny gets a lot
of contact with with regards to a lot of
aspects to parking and the car usage
electric car points i'm expecting um
councillor yates to raise that when he
when he speaks under 20.1
is another subject
whenever i travel up to to london as i
do as you will know in a coach to see a
certain football team i see a number of
on-street
charging points on route
and uh we have discussed this and the
issue is with regards to um the supplier
and the infrastructure that we have at
the moment but all of those aspects that
you raise i will make sure that they are
carried through as part of the strategy
because we need to do it and we need to
do it once and it needs to have a life
expectancy that is not one or two years
it needs to be a decade at least so
thank you very much thank you councillor
saunders
thank you and i'd ask officers to pick
up on the fact that our electric
charging points aren't working um
and one one
particular interest i have there is the
um that you mentioned was the um the
care worker permit maybe we can have a
look at um a special concession for our
care workers um
yeah i think penny yeah i mean that they
are
an absolute you know they are the angels
of the district so i think you know if
there's something we could do so i'd ask
penny if you could respond on that i
wasn't going to comment on that actually
i was going to comment on the electric
charging points sorry yeah we know they
are out of action they are out of
contract um and we are part of a
kent-wide contract to re-do all of our
electric charging points and add more so
that's the positive and we just aren't
sure when we're going to be on that
program so they have already started in
other parts of the county and we are
just waiting for our turn could i
because there was a isle of news report
when the previous administration was in
charge
and uh
the leader at the time
councillor everett there was actually a
news piece in thane i've i've downloaded
that that actually stated we would be
receiving we would have 300 new charging
points across stanic by the end of 2022
perhaps i could ask you to dig it out
and send it send it through uh yes but i
think that might be a bit ambitious but
maybe you can dish the dig the article
out and we can remember dirty would be
great
thank you point taken and again um i'll
ask um obviously cancer song is to have
a look at whether we can do something on
the care worker permits i think that'll
be yeah
certainly on the list for
our fees and charges next time we review
them but i'm hoping we can do something
um and you'll see the odds that odds are
against us even the providers
are not providing so it's not always
ourselves thank you
and no special concessions for charlton
supporters either so
next to speak under 20.1 um councillor
crittenden
thank you i'm going to try and be
mindful of the footy
um
as the originator of the motion um i
welcome uh the report and the
recommendation 3.1 in particular the
external consultant which actually isn't
repeated in in the wording of 3.1 but
i particularly welcome that um
there are a wide ranging
issues around the district i'm going to
leave it to the
external consultant to recognize that um
i obviously
hope that
the remit will include um consultation
with ward councillors and the public
um but the
the motion actually came out of the
problems in king street in ramsgate
and
one of the things i hope that the
external consultant will be able to
recognize is that there are some areas
like that that have seen an increasing
residentialization
that has meant that actually king
street's no longer a part of the town
centre in the same way as it was
and i know that they're going to be
other parts of the district that um
will also have changed and in king
street that's been a progression that
has happened over 20 years um or more
and
so just to say thank you and i hope that
it's approved um sounds all very
positive and i i've enjoyed watching the
um head shakes and the nods and from
thank you
and so they've been very positive uh
feedback that way maybe not intended but
uh yeah um
but i i do want to see an elite um that
the pressure on residential parking
alleviated um
and we do have a number of people that
you know do need to be able to drive
despite you know whatever i know we're
moving with a green agenda i i really
worry about residential parking schemes
um they are quite elitist um you know if
you can afford it great
but they do only end up spreading out
the pressure in other areas so i that is
something that concerns me but i'm going
to trust the external consultant to do
their job and thank you very much
thank you
thank you yes i mean i agree that
the
residential parking scheme that we have
in my opinion is not overly expensive
when you compare it with the
on-street charge the the the it
eliminates if you are a resident but it
is very selective to certain areas and
obviously uh those areas are subject to
other conditions that
mean that we were able to introduce the
resident parking scheme in conjunction
with kcc
and that's hopefully something that
the consultant when we get going and the
strategy will cover um obviously with my
finance hat on um i don't want it to be
the situation where we're penalizing
ourselves what we need to do is to come
up with a scheme where the residents
have the benefit and the visitors pay
for that benefit
but whether that's possible or not i
really don't know but i would like to
see summer scheme where
areas
which attract
and we have them in broad stairs
particularly on western esplanade um
etcetera along there which is
you know must be three quarters of a
mile long free parking on both sides uh
there's got to be some revenue there and
we've got to do something there to
actually offset
um our residents as far as the parking
charges are concerned
thank you
thank you councillor saunders yeah i'm
all for a toll booth it's a nicholas
roundabout i think that's the way
forward um and i'm not joking um
20.1 and speaking under 20.1 um
councillor whitehead
thank you leader
we were recently informed via councillor
saunders very prompt response to my
question at full council regarding
disabled parking provision and
enforcement that a consultant is being
appointed to aid in the development of a
new disabled parking strategy
may i confirm whether this commission is
as part of the overall strategy or
whether we are commissioning a
specialist within the area of disability
provision both to bring direct
experience and also to engage with
members of the disabled community who
have disconsiderable and first-hand
knowledge in this area
thank you
council saunders
i would hope to think that it would
become part of our overall strategy
and
one of the areas that i'm concerned with
with regards to the disabled parking and
you and i know we've had discussion on
the personalize if you want to call it
that but it's not personalized uh
parking values outside residential
properties um is that i think part of
the strategy we need to look at the
overall dimensions of those markings
because
again
the type of vehicles that the
individuals that have the blue badge
will drive and they need
some need to have access at the rear
increased access because they have
wheelchairs etc lifts etcetera
some blue badge holders don't
necessarily need that but i think we
need within the strategy to review the
minimum sizes which i have in front of
me as you would expect
i think we need to review the length
of those to reflect uh the needs of our
residents rather than the national
residents thank you
thank you councillor saunders um next to
speak under 20.1 is councilly yates
thank you leader um just um
got three questions but start with yeah
i fully support uh this motion from
council crittenden um and
especially
the way with this is talking about the
right things we are talking about key
workers people with disabilities cycle
storage pedestrian safety
um so the three questions i've got i'm
sorry to disappoint council saunders
with evs but i'm talking we're going to
talk about bike storage um so in some
london councils what they have is you
have residence parking but then you have
a bike like bicycle parking and i would
hope that the bicycle parking would be
less than the parking for cars and i see
that as bit of like um a revenue maker
for the council because if you do find
um
there is quite a lot of pavement space
uh across our towns and you if you can
have bike storage on those uh pavements
then you could actually use that as a
way of making quite considerable money
because there is
unfortunately quite a lot of bike theft
so
um hopefully we can take that on board
that's the first question second
question um
we've got mill lane just next door
really and um we do have residents just
across the road who do struggle um when
theater rolls
uh
is open because mill lane doesn't
actually open for 24 24 7.
so one potential option is to actually
keep that car park open later
and as the growth of margate happens
hopefully we'll see more revenue from
that
and my third question is just about
specific to margate
instead of just thinking about tdc
assets we have two absolutely massive
car parks right in the middle of old
town it's just the other side of old
town and that's morrison's and pound
stretcher car park
um
and i hope the consultant would would be
open
to discuss options where you actually
speak to pound stretcher who have and
even even when a weekend that car park
is empty it's in the middle of old town
um are there any opportunities that we
can actually make a deal with palm
stretcher to use that as an old town car
park
with some kind of agreement with the
council so that's
my question for number three thanks
thank you council yates um councillor
saunders um busily writing down there if
you'd like to respect them well i'm
writing them down because council yates
um shadows me on finance and you've come
up with some reasonable finance um there
and maybe it will uh if we can introduce
bicycle storage um it will save kcc
having to repaint their lamp posts on a
very regular basis um so that's that's a
good idea um
i'm not sure with the college road car
park you mentioned yes you're absolutely
right that's not overly full and i'm not
sure whether we can
get into some discussion i would hope
that we may be able to
definitely
so officer
buttons going to look at that um
and um mill lane well i think we we had
the same issue and uh we've we've had a
recent issue at
the ramsgate multi story leopold street
with regards to having those
car parks open for extended hours
it does attract some unsavory behavior
and in fact not only late at night when
i was here
earlier in the week
we had skateboarders
next door coming from the top floor
right the way down
on their skateboard so it's got to be
looked at and and to have it open that
length of time would require increased
security and um i'm not sure at this
point in time we have that sort of
resource available but it's certainly
something to think about and i'd you
know as as you quite rightly say it's a
revenue stream i think we need to
consider thank you
thank you
thank you councillor saunders um
yeah i think on the um
hopefully when our new skateboard super
duper skateboard park opens then they
will have somewhere to go
unfortunately it won't match the one at
foxton which is now a catchment area for
local um skateboarders i know that
because my great grandson's uh a
champion of his age a skateboarder
chomping at the bits to go to folks then
i will have to poach him for over here
then so
i think the um
the other point as well is that i don't
think we're actually taking enough
advantage of digital solutions for car
parking i know that we did have a pilot
scheme and i think that's still running
quite smoothly now i know it didn't in
the first place uh i'll put um trinity
trinity car park but um that is
definitely another solution that can
also aid with the resident parking
especially it can be it'll allow
flexible charges as well which can be
changed during the winter for the summer
so the more we can move towards that and
use technology then uh
maybe that all fits in with the overall
plan so um thank you for the
for the good points that you've risen
you've uh raised there
so um council saunders you have moved
the recommendation
and do i have a seconder
councillor bob baford
do members agree
moving on to item six is the margate
levelling up fund third party grant to
introduce councillors pugh
thank you chair
in june last year we approved the
decision to submit a leveling up fund
bid to central government to enable east
kent college group to deliver the
margate digital campus in october 2021
we were successfully awarded just over
6.3 million pounds to enable delivery of
this project
the council is the accountable body for
the 11 app fund and as such has an
agreement with central government to
deliver to deliver the project as
outlined in the funding submission
however it will be the responsibility of
east kent college group to deliver the
digital campus as they are the experts
in the field of education
and i definitely am not
this funding will enable the delivery of
a state-of-the-art digital skills and
training provision in the town centre
which will undoubtedly support the whole
district's economic recovery and
leveling up with its communities both in
terms of training opportunities and
pathways as well as increasing footfall
in the high street
the east kent college group will be
provided the monies for a funding grant
agreement which will include the
conditions required from the council
monitoring and evaluation and
expectations in relation to delivery of
the project
i would like to recommend that cabinet
one approve the use of grants which
exceed 250 000 pounds to third parties
to deliver the agreed department of
leveling up housing and communities
funded project
which is six point three zero six zero
seven eight
uh pounds six point three million pounds
uh capital grant to the east kent
college group to deliver the market
digital project identified in the
margate leveling up funding bid and
number two is each grant agreement is
signed under deed by the director of law
and democracy and the director of
finance and section 151 officer and is
witnessed by a member of the council
thank you
thank you council of you and to speak
under 20.1 councillor yates
thank you leader um quite a specific
question i've got so uh apologies i
haven't actually given you notice of
this question
um
and
i'd i'd like to done a bit more digging
into this but um it's just a general
question i believe margate school were
mentioned in the original bid but they
weren't
a formal stakeholder to the bid
um are they going to be involved in this
project
thanks
uh thank you council yates for your
question um i think you're right i think
there's
an ongoing discussion uh with east kent
college group and the margate school
about them potentially uh being
incorporated into some sort of space
within the digital campus um i'm not
aware of of where that is now or how
they've progressed with that louise may
able to add a little bit more
information to that but of course that
would be sorry i can't see there we go
that would be conversations between east
kent college group and the margaret
school um but i'm sure the council will
be supportive of whatever outcome
there is
yeah i'm happy to answer so um
the
the grant is for the building to bring
that back into use for the campus and
then ekc group are talking to um the
margate school about having some of that
space within the building that they will
run
um
services for students and and businesses
out of that so it will be like a lease
agreement with the college so my
understanding is those conversations are
ongoing but there'll be a third party um
and we'll need to kind of work through
the college to inform their outputs
thank you
so councillor pugh has moved the
recommendations do i have a seconder
councillor george carr
do members agree
item seven margate town deal
project grant to third parties to
introduce councillor reese pugh
thank you chair
excuse me
uh the council is also the accountable
body for the margaret town deal and
there are a number of projects within
the 22.2 million pound funding allocated
from the department for leveling up
housing and communities that will be
delivered by third parties
the margate town investment plan
includes the projects that will be
delivered and officers have been working
with the town deal board and delivery
partners to progress the green book
compliant business cases in order to
draw down the funding the business case
for the creative land trust was
completed last year and central
government has awarded the funding for
that project
trustees are being interviewed and the
charity commission has awarded the trust
with charity status
this is an incredibly exciting time for
the creative industries in than it
and the project brings with it
significant opportunities for economic
growth a capital sum of six million
pounds is allocated to the development
of the creative land trust with up to
nine hundred thousand pounds in revenue
to support participation and engagement
for people in the district to engage
with the creative sector with a
particular focus on building capacity
and providing employment pathways
only last week three more business case
summary documents were submitted to
central government including the coastal
well-being intervention
as part of this programme of projects
grass cliftonville cic is intended to
deliver a project at the oval bandstand
and gardens
in july 2021 the council transferred the
oval bandstand to grass cliftonville cic
they have developed a robust five-year
strategy which sets out a clear
commercial strategy to ensure the new
cliftonville pavilion is financially
self-sustainable
the town deal funding will enable the
delivery of improved facilities and help
to unlock other funding
in order to enable the creative land
trust and grass cliftonville cic to
deliver i would like to recommend the
following
one the cabinet approved the payments of
grants third parties to deliver the
agreed department of leveling up housing
and communities funded projects these
grant payments are six million pounds
capital grant to the margate creative
land trust to deliver the outcomes
identified in the margate town
investment plan and up to nine hundred
thousand pounds revenue fund revenue
funding for participation engagement as
part of the scaling margates creative
and production intervention and delivery
of the creative land trust and finally
five hundred thousand pounds capital
grant to grass for the oval band stand
and guidance project
and then number two each agree each
grant agreement is signed as a deed
by the director of law and democracy and
director of finance and section 151
officer and is witnessed by a member of
the council thank you
thank you councillor pugh um to speak
under 20.1 councillor yates
thank you leader um two questions again
um
first question
second bullet point where goes up to 900
000 pound revenue funding for
participation and engagement as part of
the as part of the scaling markets
creative and production intervention
comma and delivery of creative land
trust do we know what
proportion
is going towards delivery of the
creative land trust and what expected
proportion is going towards
participation and engagement um we're
talking about 900 000 pounds so i'm just
it'd be good to know that
my second question is more of a comment
but i'll say it anyway um
so six million pounds for margate
creative land trust currently i don't
believe
the trustees are finalized yet um so
then we kind of have to rely on well
what are the charitable objectives
and i think it's worth i'll read them
out anyway because i think this is
important the charities objectives are
specifically restricted to promote arts
crafts and craftsmanships for public
benefit in particular but not
exclusively by providing facilitating
access to affordable workspace for the
production of arts and crafts to those
in need in the district of planet in the
county of kent and surrounding areas
i guess my only question there is
how wide of an area is margate like for
but for purchasing this property um
because the charitable objectives say
than it so
are we taking margate as the kind of
wider margate that could be edging on
like park boards there's i don't i don't
have an objection to that i just it'd be
good to know that
well
sorry um so that's i guess that's the
second question thanks
so counselor
i would like to defer this to uh to our
director of regeneration
thanks um so your first point about
percentage for setting up the community
land trust it'll be a minimal amount in
the first year just to support the
um
recruitment of a chief executive the
majority is going to be going towards
all that participation engagement
activity and we've started to put a
paper together that will go to the land
trust board that they can approve and so
that will allocate some funding
with the anticipation that some posts
will be recruited around engagement and
capacity building for the sector so that
as the assets come online
the organization are prepared and ready
to take advantage of those opportunities
so it's a very minimal amount the it's
about engagement and pathways
um
the second point about the creative at
the sorry the charitable objectives um
the
lawyers that we engaged to um put
together the charity commission
application just advised that it was
best to keep it broader rather than
really narrow um and and they had um put
together the
charity uh application for the london
land trust and it was just through their
experience of charity work that it made
sense to make it broader just so that at
any point if it if it was looking
outside of boundaries it wasn't going to
be stifled and obviously some of
our business parks are are kind of
bordering boundaries between towns
within the district so
it made sense to do that at the time
rather than stifle it for the future
thank you
okay so
councillor pugh has
moved the recommendations
oh sorry cancer bayford
yeah thank you chairman um
i mean
with what's happening with margaret and
landscape but a lot of money coming into
than it
and in the past we've seen money coming
in and we haven't always sort of seen
the right results come out of it and
often we found out sort of almost after
the event that things didn't work out
the way they were going to
could i ask that we have a regular
report to cabinet on the progress of all
these investment funds for both margaret
and ramsay i think it's very useful
yes thank you councillor bayford um i
was sorry uh chair lead i was just gonna
say that definitely will happen
councillor bayford
yes and it's also backed up with the
scrutiny panels that are set up um for
the ramsgate and margate levelling up um
and maybe something not a scrutiny panel
but an advisory panel can can be for the
margate
town deal as well because there's so
much going on and people are getting
confused with all the different funds
coming in i mean it's a lovely situation
situation to have a problem with all
this money coming in but um yeah i think
it's um ideal and i think the website
um
is being fed regularly as well so you
know that's a good signpost to to point
people towards the different funds but
yeah i mean regular to cabinet is this
is quite important because it you know
it's watched by quite a lot of people
and uh residents and and obviously
followed by members so i think it's a
good idea
cheers sorry i just wanted to add and i
think of course we've got the margate
town deal board which i see on as a
member and it's included a lot of panel
members um so i'm not sure an advisory
panel may be you know i think we might
be trying to reinvent the wheel bit but
um certainly to check in conjunction
with officers maybe we could do a bit of
a regular kind of summary document um
that shared with members i don't think
it necessarily needs to be a member's
briefing but something that then can be
circulated that everyone knows because i
i agree certainly the regen team are
working flat out on this we're getting
we're hitting milestones all the time
and you know
the certain work and everything that's
having to be churned out there is quite
a lot going on so maybe that's something
that we can we can look into and provide
to to members
thank you
thank you for the suggestion councillor
bayford it sounded like it was popular
here so
never known to be so popular
so this
this is um this has been uh recommended
a
move by councillor pugh do i have a
secondary councillor jill bayford she's
feeling rather left out
do members agree
so moving on to um item eight um oh it's
my i've been had a car at night this
evening
so this um
is the executive appointment outside
body mansion skills and employment board
at our council meeting on the 24th of
february 2011
[Music]
but any list of outside bodies will be
split into two lists
those outside bodies that relate to
executive functions and hence should be
appointed by the cabinet and those that
are appointed by council
so it is for council to decide
um the
current situation is that the mansion
skills and employment board
um to the we've added the onto the list
of the executive outside bodies
and we just need to appoint
a representative from the cabinet and
i'm proposing that councillor pugh
agrees the cabinet agrees to appoint
councillors pugh to the manson skills
and employment mse board
so i'm moving that do i have a seconder
councillors pew
do
do members agree
so he needs some educating so
okay members well um thank you very much
for this evening and officers for your
time and that concludes the business at
um
7 57.
three minutes to kick off
you